what are the top five reasons an
investor will invest in your project
top five reasons an investor will invest
in somebody
or their project i think number one is
because
they want to help you i think anytime
you go to an investor it's somebody
who's probably in
better circumstance than you are or at
least has the ability to
help get you to the next level make your
dreams come true
i have had investors that get behind me
simply because
there's a trust level there's a feeling
of wanting to help me get to another
level of my career
sometimes it's because they feel the
project's important
often it's because they want
to get a tax write-off i mean there's
the business side of the business too
you know i i
believe that you know astute investors
are taught by business managers to avoid
three or four different investments one
one is nightclubs and restaurants one is
recording studios
and the other is movies i mean that's
just like those are the three you don't
do
so getting private equity together for
making motion pictures is
is difficult we have kind of a stigma
going in there's already a couple of
strikes against us so
what's important is that we're able to
appeal to an
independent and i'm sorry what's
important is that we're able to
[Music]
appeal to individual financiers or
investors with what it is that we're
trying to achieve with our work i think
that's really important and i
as i talk about a lot in my book i think
it's really important for
for filmmakers to really do their
research on people don't just go meet
rich people
meet people who can identify with what
it is you're trying to do
you may have a passion project that you
want to do but
you can do your research on a specific
investor and learn that they may have a
passion or an interest
think about doing something that is
something that they will be more open or
interested in doing
and go down that road so when you meet
with them they're excited and thrilled
about what it is you're trying to pitch
take care of business do that and then
they're going to come usually if it's
successful in a good
a good journey and say what is it you
want to do and that's often been the
hardest thing because you know again as
filmmakers we're myopic we think about
what we want to do
and often you have to think about what
other people want to do that are in a
position of helping us so
i always say go in with an open heart
going with an open mind be willing to
bob and weave a little bit off of your
plan
at the end of the day the goal is to
work the goal is to make new
relationships i mean i have investors
that we've known for 35 years that have
faithfully gotten involved i have
investors that have invested
one time that i've known 25 years and
we're still best of friends and they did
it one time and
didn't ruin the friendship it just they
wanted to try and i
i have you know friends that i've i've
known for
25 and 30 years who would never invest
in this business and they're more than
capable
it's just to each his own but i think
people will want to i i say you know you
always have to remember you're
under the watchful eye if you are going
to approach people
to invest in you realize
you're going to become an open book
they're going to look at your social
media they're going to look at how you
conduct yourself they're going to invite
you to parties where there's going to be
alcohol because they want you to drink
and they want to see how you're going to
behave
people don't realize that i mean i know
a lot of real close calls friends of
mine have had over the years we're like
god you know i had an investor on the
hook
had this party i drank too much passed
out at the guys play well
duh you know they're they're almost
saying
here let me see how you do what can i
trust you with and just remember
you have to treat their money like it's
your money and i think you know some of
the success that we've had with our
investors it's not always about how much
the return on investment was it's about
a trust level
it's about the experience let them feel
involved you know i send my investors
emails at the end of every night telling
them good better and different how the
day went
and then once we're in post-production i
i fill them in once a week
and it's that way in pre-production too
i just feel that they they're we're
doing what we do because they trust in
us and they give us the means to do it
you have to let them feel involved
and a lot of times these investors
believe it or not or a little bored
doing what they do and they see this as
kind of a neat little fun outlet so
involve them
you know let them feel a part of what
you're doing
that being said have you ever put money
from a credit card
into any of your projects have i ever
put money
from a credit card into one of my
projects um oh
yeah um there's been times where i've
done
uh self-funded projects you know i talk
about the 500 pilot i talk about the 10
movie i mean i had an investor that came
to me with twenty thousand dollars
and said i wanna make a movie with you
and
um didn't account for
sag bonds and the fact that it was kind
of a sequel remake to something we did
that was on sag
experimental and had to repay all the
actors for the work they did the year
before
so that 20 000 turned into 12 000 really
quick
and the investor was cool enough to say
i'll throw an additional amount in for
the bond but that's it because he would
get his bond back so we really had about
12 grand to work with
and there was a couple of days that it
was kind of like all right you know
let's feed the crew well tonight and
just you know it's part of it
um but i've never had to like
max out a credit card to make a movie or
anything i'm i
haven't had to do that i maxed out
credit cards doing other stupid
i know no swearing i had to throw that
no more jet skis though no more
testicles
that's over that's over
it's a good question though yeah no i
mean it's about we did dark side i put
about 3 500
on credit cards to feed i just the
people weren't eating well enough and
the budget was so cheap and they were
all working for nothing and it was like
goddamn i gotta i gotta feed these guys
so i just i told my wife i'm like i i
can't
do the subway and pizza thing for 15
days we're gonna feed them every three
days really well
but we did we did and i think we got i
think we got a good result from that you
know and you feed them well happy crew
happy moving right just want to be fed
and respected
you know if you invest 250 000 in a
movie does that mean it's going to sell
for at least 250
000 oh hell no it's like putting 75
million into a movie and sometimes it
makes back 10 million i mean
there's no guarantees obviously the more
money you have to play with
hopefully the better the cast the more
bankable the cast the more well-known
the cast but you don't always have that
i mean we've done a lot of 250 000
movies and i think again it comes
down to telling a good story it comes
down to getting a good cast that's
recognizable and marketable
and it's also about those locations you
know
take people places they want to go make
them never feel like they're watching a
250 000
movie you know i take a lot of pride in
in my 20 000
movie we really did for 12 grand a lot
of people don't know the story of that
and what it did for my career i actually
got more out of my career because of
that
than i did from gridiron gang um and i
did it after gridiron gang
what's interesting is is i had done a
film i wanted to tell a story
and i um for me it was about showing
people what i could do on a dime that's
as you know if you've read my book it's
about making films for a dime
that turn and make a dollar that's what
it's about so
for me i went out and we made this let's
just say twelve thousand dollar movie
after i put in a few grand on my credit
card to feed
um i had a friend who was very tight
with sumner redstone who at the time who
you know he just passed but sometimes
they had a viacom and a friend of mine
got it to sumner and said
friend of mine made this i don't know if
you want to watch it or not
i want you to watch it and check it out
he's like why am i watching it well
there's pretty girls in it you'll like
it
but i want you to watch it for the
production value when you're done
watching i want you to guess what you
made it for
so sumner sat through this 90-minute
debacary of mine
it wasn't a great story it just was a
pretty movie and he
was pleased and impressed with it and
glad he watched it and he said oh i
guess he probably put a couple million
into it
and my friend said well he actually put
about 12 grand into it
sumner picked up the phone called brad
gray god rest him he's dead too
picked up the phone and called brad gray
and said i just saw a movie that
apparently was made for twelve thousand
five hundred dollars
i could have sworn it was made for a
couple million i need to get it to you
film got sent to brat i got a call from
brad gray the next day
he said yeah i need you to start meeting
with our people we want to get you in
here i met with les moonves i met with
michael balbre who was running paramount
at the time
and it opened up amy powell who was
running in surge which is you know did
paranormal activity and a lot of other
great films and
that film opened up a lot of doors for
me because it showed people what i could
do for a dime
and it and it allowed my investors to
come back out of the woodwork who i
hadn't worked with in many years because
you know you go make a film with
sony you're not hitting people up for a
quarter million dollars to make movies
you're making a you know you're making a
studio movie
so it reopened those great opportunities
and kind of
just reminded me okay you don't need big
budgets to make
something look nice now we just got to
focus on making better movies
and it's been a fun journey but yeah we
um
or david bulberry was the guy at
paramount but um
it opened those doors for me that you
know having a number one blockbuster
never got me so i really encourage
people to make those low-budget
glossy good-looking films if your story
sucks
they better look good and i went in on
the merit of guess what i did it for
and um people thought you know 600 000
most people who were in the know figured
to a million it was a 20 000 15 000
movie
yeah that actually ended up being 12
because didn't you
you lost some of the money what was it
20 credits 20 or 25 000
was the original agreement but because
of our
previous jaw with sag and those actors
we had to repay them for their first
so we lost about eight grand of sag so
that came down to about 12
and then you know we ended up
you know probably putting in about 2 800
of my own for food
and stuff so yeah you know about 15 000.
wow
how long was the shoot how many days 12
days 12 days shoot
did it i did a day of uh i did a day
of second unit with two of the actors
because they were friends of mine they
did it off the grid you know i wanted
them in the car driving
you know drive-bys and stuff and then i
went out and just grabbed a camera and
just second united the hell out of it
you know got those great magic hour
shots and just filled up the
just filled it up with some pretty you
know but it was well shot it was
well-acted
um you know we had sean young betsy
russell from saw
ron masak who's been in everything
courtney gaines from children of the
corn i mean every face in it was
recognizable
jason pace ryan um oh i'm blanking on
ryan's name it's my fault there was just
some really good talent in that film and
i was proud of it because it looked
pretty it was a beautiful movie it was a
horrible movie but it was a beautiful
movie
why was it horrible it was just stupid
it was you know i did i
i did the first one which was a pure
story about a story i wanted to tell
and that was the pilot that i did for
500 bucks and somebody saw it and said
oh my god you got to make a sequel to
this
and that was that was the mistake
story-wise there was no sequel
but somebody was throwing 20 bucks you
know 20 grand down to make a movie
i'm not doing anything this week let's
do it you know and so we did it
do you think that if you'd had more time
you said it was a 12-day shoot if you'd
had more time would it have been better
or
no the story was fundamentally it was a
horrible script no it looked good i mean
you know again it's a 15 12 to 15 000
movie that some people thought we spent
600 000 to 2 million to make
so it visually was fine it was
it was just the script was written in
like a week and it was just no
development notes it was like oh here
was the prequel just just let's just
carry on and write and tell a story and
it was it was just
you know it's more of an experiment i
see yeah it was fun
you